Oh
[Music]
Kelly Thomas died a few days after that
beating today in court were hearing
accusations of how Thomas was pummeled
and left lying in a pool of his own
blood and on the night of July 5th 2011
he posed no threat at all to the police
or to anyone else
the suspect was uncontrollable couldn't
handcuff him they couldn't control him
an officer is trained basically to
control secure and that trained to tie
and this was not even a time prosecutor
said that the last words out of his
mouth where God helped me daddy they're
trying to kill me daddy during opening
statements from the DA you know choked
me up again with Kelly calling out for
me without that city video
Kelly would just be like everybody else
who was murdered by the police and that
would never have been charges you'll
hear Kelly saying oh it's okay I'm sorry
I'm sorry a client didn't use excessive
force who had reasonable they tried
their best and it wasn't enough force to
contain
it also enlightens me tell the garbage
the fence is going to do it I can only
hope that the jury isn't swayed
why the tricks and antics I suspect who
is acting consistently was somebody with
a methamphetamine background and a
methamphetamine psychosis the
unfortunate abuse the drugs over years
the straight life that's happened in
this case it's a tragedy but it's not a
crime
and if defense did exactly what they
were out to do and that's to make Kelly
look very bad horrible violent drug
crazed you know but I think keep Tonya
they don't have to prove any of it and
he repeated many times just over and
over again on this desperate crying
voice that he was sorry like a young boy
begging for the punishment to stop
please I can't breathe